heute habe ich lange nicht mehr richtig
videos gemacht mal schauen wie es um
einen kanal steht
ok oh nein weniger view 36 tage weniger
hat als letzten tage
vielleicht bin ich einfach nicht mehr im
trend guck mir mal was im trend ist
youtube trends bleibt immer auf dem
laufenden über die angesagtesten trends
auf youtube g20 sollte ich mein aufnahme
zimmer kaputt machen
ist das da spiele niemals um drei uhr
nachts charlie charlie challenge okay
nein das erst in der schlussminute die
bewertung ausgeschaltet er stand 14 uhr
mittags größte verarschen konflikt drei
uhr nachts findet das ganze stadt einig
dass jede menge leute an 54.000
abonnenten 200.000 wir uns in den
kommentaren
naja da draußen ist eindeutig dunkel
also auf jeden fall nicht fähig
ich gebe mal hier drei uhr nachts ein
kontrast etwa 600.000 aufrufe revox
200.000 aufrufe ok mit leute also steht
fest ich brauche das auch ich muss
irgendwie auch drei uhr nachts video
machen okay leute lang warten erstmal ab
83 wird
so leute ich kann so laut sprechen
die tiroler kam drei und ich will
schauen was passiert genau hinhören
jeder menge musik im hintergrund mache
ich nicht ich sondern das stückchen ist
das machtwort von 386 bin ich weil ich
hab keine serie fragen wie später setzte
später in 1 33 und wie passiert nicht
obwohl 30 890 verflucht
ich weiß nicht wo mein gott leute ich
habe einfach nur so zum spaß hier
gefragt und seht ihr das da drüben im
hintergrund das sind zwar keine
studenten
[Musik]
so spaziert leute diese 83 videos sind
wirklich wahr ich dachte immer sehr
schwach wegen gestorben ich ganz ehrlich
bin habe ich gar keine ahnung was mit
ihm wieder aussagen wollte ich freue
mich einfach noch ein bisschen darüber
dass sie machen dass diese drei urteilen
wirklich lächerlich ist und ja also das
ganze hat jetzt früchte getragen hat
euch das video angeschaut weil das ganze
ist ja irgendwie ein verzweifelter
versuch wieder mehr klicks und news zu
machen und vielleicht auch besser wenn
ihr das video unglaublich gut findet
lasst doch mal ein abo da so dreht man
drei uhr nachts video ich bin
unwahrscheinlich dem tisch